if you fly Delta Airlines you could soon
breeze through Airport check-in and
security just by showing your face the
nation's first biometric airport
terminal launches tomorrow in Atlanta
the system will allow passengers to go
from curb to gate and onto the plane
without showing their passports but the
new technology also raises some privacy
concerns Kris Van Cleave is at
hartsfield-jackson International Airport
with a look at this new system I'm
intrigued Chris good morning good
morning well you see all of these lights
here these are all cameras some of the
84 that have been installed in this
terminal basically here's how it works
you go up to the camera if the light
turns green your face has been verified
you don't need your boarding pass or
your passport and that's pretty much how
it's gonna work at the kiosks even TSA
at TSA it'll save you 20 seconds a
person but at the gate it's a big
time-saver up to nine minutes of flight
face the cameraman fliers are checking
in to the future right there at
Atlanta's international terminals mouth
camera
starting tomorrow terminal F will be the
nation's first fully biometric Airport
experience allowing passengers to just
use their face at a kiosk to check bags
at the counter go through security sir
I'll get you right here and even board
flights anything to keep me from getting
in the lines and time is money the
system takes a picture and compares it
against a digital copy of a traveler's
passport photo stored in a secure
customs and border protection database
of people flying that day thank you
thank you it takes as little as two
seconds speed wind certainly from a
customer view point Gill West is Delta's
chief operating officer initially it's
for international flights from u.s.
stations I do see a future where this
will be used for domestic flights how
are you
perfect this is all about saving time
the camera can verify my identity in
seconds it's faster than me going
through my passport giving it to her she
then scans it to verify my identity it's
about saving time but it's not without
some controversy how big of a threat to
people's privacy is this biometrics
program it's a massive threat and I
don't say that lightly what the program
is doing is making a common place to use
your face as a digital ID Republican
Senator Mike Lee and Democrat Ed Markey
have called on Customs and Border
Protection to stop expanding this
biometric program partially mandated by
Congress until the agency implements
privacy regulations and provides a
report to Congress on the viability of
biometrics if the rules haven't been
made and there's not a regulation for
you to follow we're just kind of having
to take your word for it
well US citizens can opt out of having
the airline collect their photograph and
transmit to CBP John Wagner deputy
executive assistant commissioner at CBP
is the architect of the system how well
does the system work we're seeing 98 to
99 percent match rates as flight 185 to
Shanghai boarded we watched most
passengers opt to use the facial
recognition system to board the plane do
you have any concerns about who's
keeping the picture of your face I'm not
worried about it I mean this is the
world we live in TS I already has it so
what's the difference
Delta's expanding this to Detroit next
the airline says it doesn't keep any of
the photos that are taken Customs holds
on to the photos of US citizens for
about 12 hours before they're deleted
from the system CBP has been testing
biometrics at 15 airports and three land
border crossings in the last few months
alone the system has flagged 34 people
entering the United States with someone
else's passport that is illegal what oh
that's interesting yeah that's yeah I'm
down for it because as you said there's
cameras everywhere so why not